Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. When shall we three meet again in thunder, lightning or in rain? Some of the most famous words ever written by Shakespeare. And they're spoken, of course, by one of the witches in Macbeth. And witches and witchcraft, these are the theme of today's episode of The Rest Is History. But wait, before we go any further, by the pricking of my thumbs, something wicked this way comes. Dominic Sandbrook, how are you doing?
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、系列节目的抢先体验，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。我们三个人什么时候再相聚？在雷电交加之中，还是在细雨里？这是莎士比亚写下的最著名的台词之一。它们当然出自《麦克白》（Macbeth）中的一位女巫之口。而女巫与巫术，正是今天这期《历史的余烬》的主题。但是等等，在我们深入探讨之前——凭我大拇指的刺痛，必有邪恶的事情发生。多米尼克·桑德布鲁克（Dominic Sandbrook），你好吗？
Sledgehammer wit, Tom, as ever. I'm very well, thank you. How are you? The rapier shark slash. So, Dominic, a fan of the dark arts a practitioner perhaps uh no i've got a lot of dark art stuff in my house because my son is massively into jk rowling i know jk rowling is persona non grata in some quarters but this is definitely a rolling friendly household so my house is stuffed with witchcraft and wizardry and all that sort of carry on brilliant well that that should give us something to talk about be good perhaps to get on to on to Harry Potter at some point in this podcast.
汤姆，一如既往地犀利幽默。我很好，谢谢。你呢？锐剑般的反手一击。所以，多米尼克，你是黑魔法的粉丝，还是说是个实践者？呃，没有，我家里有很多黑魔法相关的东西，因为我儿子迷J·K·罗琳迷得不行。我知道J·K·罗琳在某些圈子里不受欢迎，但这里绝对是一个“罗琳友好型”家庭，所以我的家里塞满了巫术、魔法以及诸如此类的事情。太棒了，那这应该能给我们提供不少谈资，在这个播客的某个时候，聊聊《哈利·波特》也许会很不错。
But we're very honoured to be joined today by our special guest, Susanna Lipscomb, star of TV, who also happens to be Professor of History at Roehampton University, the author of a series of award-winning books on early modern history, including, most recently, The Voices of Nîmes, about women women sex and marriage in reformation long doc but she's also the author more germainly for our purposes of the recently published ladybird book of witchcraft susie so good to have you great title
不过今天非常荣幸能邀请到我们的特邀嘉宾苏珊娜·利普斯康姆（Susanna Lipscomb），她是一位电视明星，同时也是罗汉普顿大学（Roehampton University）的历史学教授，著有一系列关于早期现代史的获奖书籍，其中最新的一部是《尼姆的声音》（The Voices of Nîmes），讲述了宗教改革时期朗格多克（Languedoc）的女性、性别与婚姻；但对我们今天的节目而言，更切题的是，她还是新近出版的《瓢虫巫术简史》（Ladybird book of witchcraft）的作者。苏西，很高兴你能来，这个书名太棒了。
yes we've moved on slightly from jack and jill with the. Well, it's a great series. I've also written one, so I know that it's the very highest quality scholarship. And witchcraft, was this a subject that you kind of got into on the back of your interest in early modern history, or was it the other way around? It's sort of the other way around, because my supervisor for my doctorate was Robin Briggs, who's a great scholar of witchcraft and looked at the witches the trials of witches in Lorraine particularly which is one of the
是的，比起《杰克和吉尔》（Jack and Jill），我们的内容稍微进阶了一点。嗯，这是一个很棒的系列。我也写过一本，所以我知道这是最高水准的学术研究。那么，巫术，你是出于对早期现代史的兴趣而接触到这个主题的，还是反过来呢？有点算是反过来，因为我读博士时的导师是罗宾·布里格斯（Robin Briggs），他是一位伟大的巫术研究学者，专门研究洛林（Lorraine）的巫术和女巫审判，洛林是那些特别热衷于处决女巫的独立公国之一。
independent duchies that was particularly keen on executing witches and my college advisor was who's worked on witchcraft and the witch craze in Germany so I mean I was I barely evaded witchcraft and the witch craze in Germany. So I mean, I was I barely evaded witchcraft, frankly, as my personal studies. So it's sort of not surprising at all that I've come around to it in the end. So there's so much to get into. I guess the big question, Susie, is, is witchcraft a kind of constant in human history? Have we always believed in witches? I mean, I'm guessing you'll say kind of yes and no, will you? Yes, we have always believed in witches, it seems. So the earliest case that I've come across is, and this is far more Tom's territory than mine, is ancient Greece. So it's about 330 BC. There was an alleged witch called Theurus of Lemnos. And so she was prosecuted for casting incantations
而我的大学导师是……他研究过德国的巫术和女巫狂热。所以我的意思是，我几乎可以说是险些把德国的巫术和女巫狂热选作我的个人研究方向。因此，我最终兜兜转转又回到这个主题上，其实一点也不让人意外。这里有太多内容可以探讨了。我想最大的问题是，苏西，巫术可以说是人类历史上的某种常态吗？我们是否一直都相信女巫的存在？我的猜测是，你的回答大概会是“既是也不是”，对吗？是的，看起来我们似乎一直都相信女巫的存在。我遇到的最早的案例——这其实比我更符合汤姆的专业领域——是古希腊。大约是在公元前330年。当时有一个被指控为女巫的人，名叫莉姆诺斯的瑟乌里斯（Theurus of Lemnos）。她因诵咒语
and using harmful drugs. And then we see it appear again and again throughout time. Basically, time is punctuated by there being witchcraft cases, whether you're talking 30 BC or just after the AD, BC, or I don't call it anymore anymore but you know what i mean but just the um into the modern era and um and we see this throughout the anglo-saxons we see it in medieval period and so the period i've particularly worked on is where those beliefs become prosecutions where there's a particularly serious uh craze i suppose um and people are concerned
和使用有害药物而被起诉。然后我们看到这种现象在历史的长河中一次又一次地出现。基本上，时间的刻度就是由一个接一个的巫术案件标示出来的，无论你说的是公元前30年，还是公元后刚开始的时候——我现在不再用公元前、公元后这种叫法了，但你懂我的意思——总之，一直延续到现代。我们在盎格鲁-萨克逊时期看到了这种现象，在中世纪也能看到。所以我特别研究的时期，是那些信仰转化为实际起诉的时期，也就是出现了一场特别严重的、呃，我想可以说是“狂热”的时期，人们忙于
with trying to persecute witches under law and then have them executed but they've been with us throughout time so is there is the big shift um from thinking witchcraft was fine and it was just something that people did it might be a bit, but it was kind of carrying on to thinking that it was sinful and must be extirpated at all costs. I don't think it was a form of heresy. Right. I think that's the shift. Yeah, because I was wondering about heresy, because famously the Middle Ages, described by R.A. Moore, is a persecuting society. And the definite sense you get with heresy, and Dominic, we talked about this in relation to the supposed Cathars.
根据法律试图迫害女巫，然后将她们处决。但她们自古以来就伴随着我们。那么，最大的转变是什么？是从认为巫术没问题、只是人们的一种寻常行为——可能有点小古怪，但总体还在继续——转变为认为巫术是罪恶的，必须不惜一切代价将其根除？我不认为它最初是一种异端。对，我认为这才是真正的转变。是的，因为我在想关于异端的问题，众所周知，被R·A·摩尔（R. A. Moore）描述为“迫害性社会”的中世纪。对于异端，你绝对能感觉到——多米尼克，我们曾讨论过所谓的卡特里派（Cathars）——
We did. Is that you get kind of friars, learned scholars who go back to classical antiquity and kind of plunder it for source material. And then they kind of create a package and then they project it onto people and it kind of catches fire. And I guess the is what happens with witchcraft that essentially, what is it? It's by the kind of the 14th century and then really into the 15th century that the church starts to conflate sorcery with heresy and so the assumption becomes that if you were having dealings with the devil then in a sense you are no longer christian and therefore you must be targeted for that reason yeah so it's the end of the 15th century, and it particularly happens through the famous book,
确实如此。你会发现有些修士、博学的学者，他们回溯到古典古代，从中搜寻并掠夺原始素材。然后他们把这些素材打包整合，再投射到人们身上，于是它就像星星之火一样燎原了。我想，巫术是不是也是这样？本质上，它是什么？到了14世纪，特别是进入15世纪时，教会开始将妖术与异端混为一谈，因此人们开始产生这样一种假设：如果你与魔鬼有来往，那么从某种意义上说，你就不再是基督徒了，因此你必须成为被打击的目标。对，所以那是15世纪末，
Malleus Maleficarum, The Hammer of the Witches, which was written by a German Dominican monk called Heinrich Kramer. And he reproduced a papal bull that had recently been published that said that witches were heretics. So it's exactly that that's happening in terms of elevating the threat of witchcraft from being a local sorcerer to being something that is on a kind of this transcendental level where, you know, there's this absolute threat to souls as well as lives. And so I think that's crucial. And then the other shift that happens is that once that has the weight of the church or supposed weight of the church behind it, then we see it starting to be accepted at an elite level. And indeed, we even get demonologies written by members of the elites, including a reigning monarch. And we end up with seeing it becoming a crime under law. So there's kind of two shifts. So it becomes seen as heresy, and then becomes seen as a crime. And that's a crucial thing that has to happen in the 16th
这主要是通过一本著名的书实现的，《女巫之锤》（Malleus Maleficarum），由一位名叫海因里希·克雷默（Heinrich Kramer）的德国多米尼克会修士所写。他在书中转载了一份最近刚发布的教宗诏书，其中称女巫为异端。正是这种做法，将巫术的威胁从地方性的妖术，拔高到了一种超验的层面上。在这里，你可以看到它对灵魂以及生命构成了绝对的威胁。我认为这至关重要。随之而来的另一个转变是，一旦这有了教会的背书——或者说被认为有教会的背书——我们就会看到它开始在精英阶层中被接受。事实上，我们甚至看到精英阶层（包括在位君王）撰写了魔鬼学著作。最终，它在法律上成了一种犯罪。所以这里面大约有两种转变：首先它被视为异端，然后被视为犯罪。这是在16世纪必须发生的一个关键转变。
century. And why does that happen where it does? So obviously, Germany is, you mentioned Linda Roper, and she wrote that great book about witchcraft in Germany. And in England, we think of it as, you know, the Witchfinder General Matthew Hopkins, and we obviously witchcraft in Scotland, and then the American colonies, the crucible and all that kind of carry on. But I'm not aware that it's such a big deal in, you know, Spain or Italy or something. Is it places where, I mean, to a sort of layman, it would look like it's places with a lot of Protestants. Is that right? It certainly does it's places with a lot of Protestants. Is that right? It certainly does happen in places with a lot of Protestants.
为什么它偏偏在那些地方发生？显然，德国是——你提到了琳达·罗珀（Linda Roper），她写过那本关于德国巫术的伟大著作；而在英格兰，我们会想到搜巫总长马修·霍普金斯（Matthew Hopkins）；当然还有苏格兰的巫术，然后是美洲殖民地、《萨勒姆的女巫》（The Crucible）以及所有这类的后续事件。但我并不知道它在西班牙或意大利等地也是一件这么大的事。这是发生在那些有大量新教徒的地方吗？是这样吗？它确实发生在有大量新教徒的地方。
And I think it helps, as it were, I think in areas where there's a particularly kind of hot form of Protestantism. So in England, it becomes to be called Puritanism. It means that people have a kind of piebald mentality they see the world in black and white they see the devil at work everywhere and it's certainly true that in areas like scotland um in east anglia and essex there and in parts of germany we are we do have a particularly sort of inflamed um no pun intended, culture around Protestantism. And so that is true. But there are trials, although there are fewer,
而且我认为，在那些存在某种狂热新教形式的地区，情况确实如此。在英格兰，这被称为清教主义（Puritanism）。这意味着人们有一种斑驳的心态：他们用非黑即白的眼光看待世界，认为魔鬼在到处作祟。确实，在苏格兰、东盎格利亚、埃塞克斯以及德国的部分地区，我们确实拥有这种特别被点燃的——绝非双关——围绕新教的文化。所以这是真的。不过也有审判，虽然数量较少，
there are trials in Catholic areas. So, for example, I mentioned Lorraine, the Duchy of Lorraine, which is broadly Catholic, and there are many trials there. There aren't that many in France, about 3,000 over the period, which is not that many, but there are some in Spain. So there are trials in Catholic areas. It's not quite so clear cut as just being Protestant. And I think it's because in this period, whether you're Protestant or Catholic, you're concerned about what is wrong in terms of faith, that the Reformation has produced this kind of
但在天主教地区也有审判。例如，我提到的洛林公国，大致上是天主教的，那里也有很多审判。法国的审判其实并不算多，这一时期大约有3,000起，不算很多，但西班牙也有一些。所以在天主教地区也有审判。它并非像仅仅是“新教”那么非黑即白。我认为这是因为在此期间，无论你是新教徒还是天主教徒，你都对信仰中什么是错误的问题感到担忧，宗教改革引发了这种对末日的焦虑氛围，担心魔鬼是否在作祟。也许在新教徒当中这种情况稍微多一点，但天主教徒显然也很关注这一点。
atmosphere of angst about the end days, about whether the devil was at work. Perhaps it's slightly more the case amongst Protestants, but Catholics are certainly concerned about it as well. Well, Susie, there's a brilliant comment by carlos a who says that um that hunting witches was actually the most intensely ecumenical event of the reformation era which is a kind of sober way of putting it and he kind of talks about you know it's almost one of the few aspects of theology where catholics are reading protestants and and vice versa and i i was wondering i mean essentially the kind of the real peak of the witchcraft craze is latter half of the 16th century moving into the 17th century and that's also when
嗯，苏西，卡洛斯·A（Carlos A）有一个精彩的评论，他说——狩猎女巫其实是宗教改革时代最具内聚力的普世大同事件，这是一种相当清醒的表述。他谈到，这几乎是神学中为数不多的几个领域之一：天主教徒在阅读新教徒的著作，反之亦然。我在想，本质上，巫术狂热真正的顶峰是在16世纪后半叶到17世纪，这也是新教徒和天主教徒在反宗教改革的浪潮中，各自的宗派认同真正加剧的时期。而作为一种反作用，他们之间开始爆发战争，也就是宗教战争。巫术的盛行、对巫术的焦虑，与天主教徒和新教徒在参战时所抱有的——即他们正在进行某种善恶之间的宇宙之战的信念——之间，是否存在某种联系？
confessional identities among Protestants and among Catholics in the wake of the counter reformation are really intensifying and again as kind of a counter effect that is that you start to get warfare between them religious war is there a link between the prevalence of witchcraft the growth the anxiety about witchcraft and the sense that presumably both catholics and protestants have when they're going to war that they're engaged in some kind of cosmic battle between good and evil. There certainly is. There certainly is this connection that actually they're living in a time of anarchy, spiritual anarchy. And, you know, pretty much no one in the 16th century and early 17th century thinks that toleration is a good idea. You know, they think there's a right way and there's a wrong way and you need to root out that which is wrong.
确实存在。确实存在这样一种联系：实际上，他们生活在一个无政府状态、精神无政府状态的时代。你知道，在16世纪和17世纪初，几乎没有人认为宗教宽容是个好主意。你知道，他们认为有正确的方法，也有错误的方法，你需要根除错误的东西。
So it's certainly that's the background to it. I think we have to be careful that it's quite just to prevent against thinking this is Protestants attacking Catholics. Very few instances where that's the case or vice versa. speaking it's that as that lovely quote makes clear it's something that everybody's doing at the time that witches are thought to be a threat overall because people are much more concerned about evil at work in the world um they they differ on their definition of which particular version of faith is correct but they do think there's a right and the wrong way and witches are clearly on the wrong side susie let's talk a bit about witches themselves. So the sort of standard view of the witches, I guess,
所以这绝对是事件的背景。我想我们必须小心，不要盲目地认为这是新教徒在攻击天主教徒。这种情况很少发生，反之亦然。总体而言，正如那句精彩的名言所阐明的，这是当时所有人都在做的事情。人们认为女巫整体上是一种威胁，因为人们更加关注世上作祟的邪恶。他们对哪种特定版本的信仰才是正确的定义各不相同，但他们都认为有对错之分，而女巫显然站在了错误的一边。苏西，我们来谈谈女巫本身吧。关于女巫的某种标准看法，我想，
is that they are women, older women, childless widows, who are marginal in their village. And it tends to be villages, right, rather than big towns. And is that right? Or is it more complicated than that? I mean, do you ever get a male witch, witch for example so there's a lot to unpack there so yes it tends to be villages rather than towns because most people live in villages right so you don't have that many um like 95% of the population or more lives in villages and and small places under 400 people. And it's true that most witches that are convicted are women
是她们身为女性，年长的女性，无依无靠的寡妇，在村庄里处于边缘地位。而且往往是在村庄里，对吧，而不是大城镇？是这样吗？还是说情况要复杂得多？我的意思是，有没有过男性女巫的例子？这里面有很多内容需要剖析。是的，它往往发生在村庄而不是城镇，因为大多数人都住在村庄里，对吧？所以你不会有那么多——比如95%甚至更多的总人口都住在村庄和400人以下的小地方。而且确实，大多数被定罪的女巫都是女性，
and they're older women. Crucially, they're menopausal or postmenopausal. They are often widowed. They have ceased to have children. They're no longer fertile. And those are really important things. And there are lots of reasons for why they're old for why it's older women being attacked but it's not just women so for example
而且是年长的女性。关键在于，她们处于更年期或绝经后。她们往往是寡妇。她们不再生育孩子。她们不再具有生育能力。这些都是非常重要的特征。关于为什么她们年纪大、为什么受攻击的是年长女性，有很多原因，但并不仅仅局限于女性。例如，
it particularly during the severe panics 1611 for example in Elwangen in Germany there are 430 people who are executed as witches and they are men and women they include priests they include a judge who's protested about his wife's arrest sometimes witches and this is pretty terrible deviation as it were from the stereotype are children so again in Germany in the 1620s in Würzburg, there are, I think it's more than 40 children who are executed as children. That happens in the Basque country.
特别是在严重的恐慌期间——比如1611年德国埃尔旺根（Elwangen），有430人被当作女巫处决，其中既有男性也有女性，包括神职人员，甚至还有一个曾抗议妻子被捕的法官。有时女巫——这堪称对刻板印象的极其可怕的偏离——竟然是儿童。同样是在1620年代的德国维尔茨堡（Würzburg），有，我想有40多名儿童作为儿童被处决。这种情况也发生在巴斯克地区。
Happens in Sweden. Have you seen the, a friend of mine made a film for Dispatches on Channel 4 about 10 years ago. I think it was called Savouring Africa's Witch Children. I mean, we're massively moving forwards now. But this is in southern Nigeria, where, of course, it's become a very radical form of Protestantism, but it's fused with local beliefs in spirits and demons. And there, there's a whole kind of strain of protestantism that says that um that witches are everywhere and
发生在瑞典。你看过——我的一个朋友大约10年前为第四频道（Channel 4）的《时事追踪》（Dispatches）制作过一部纪录片。我想它叫《品味非洲的巫童》（Savouring Africa's Witch Children）。我的意思是，我们现在的发展跨度已经非常大了。但这是在尼日利亚南部，在那里，这当然变成了一种非常激进的新教形式，但它与当地对精灵和恶魔的信仰融合在了一起。在那里，存在着一整支清教主义流派，他们声称
that children are particularly prone to being um witches and children who get accused of it get kind of at best expelled from the family at worst tortured to death um and i wondered you know is is that showing that we're talking about something that is universal and constant? Or is it the fact that it's the Protestantism, it's the Christianity that is inspiring this? Or what's going on there? Can we kind of trace the patterns all the way through history, do you think? It's a difficult thing to answer. I mean, it's certainly true that we have, there have been many witch hunts in recent times um so um in the late 80s early 90s there were 200 lynchings of suspected witches in south africa um there have been that in um
女巫无处不在，儿童特别容易成为女巫，而那些被指控为女巫的儿童，往好了说被逐出家庭，往坏了说被折磨至死。我在想，这是否表明我们正在讨论的是一种普遍且恒定的现象？还是说，是新教、是基督教激发了这一切？这背后到底是怎么回事？你认为我们能一路在历史上追踪到这些模式吗？这是一个很难回答的问题。我的意思是，确实，近年来发生过很多次猎巫行动——比如在80年代末90年代初，南非发生了200起针对疑似女巫的私刑；在2001年，民主刚果共和国，
2001 in the democratic republic of congo there were unofficially, officially it figures around 800, unofficially we're told it's more running into the thousands, witches killed, you know, murdered by lynching mobs, as it were. Saudi Arabia created an anti-witchcraft unit in 2009. So it's, and we've seen it more recently, even, you know, wherever you look around the world, Nepal, Colombia, Indonesia, Nigeria. So it's a constant for sure. And I suppose even in Britain, I mean, Dominic, I don't know if you've researched
非官方统计显示有大约800人，官方数据则是更多，据说有数千名女巫被私刑暴徒杀害。沙特阿拉伯在2009年设立了一个反巫术单位。所以，这绝对是一种常态。我想甚至在不列颠，多米尼克，我不知道你是否研究过
the ritual satanic abuse scandals. Yeah, the 80s. Yeah. So was, in a sense, that's a kind of witchcraft scare, isn't it? Yeah, I suppose you could probably argue that. I mean, there's clearly, well, I don't know, maybe Susie would disagree with this,
邪教虐童丑闻？对，80年代的那个。所以，从某种意义上说，那也是一种巫术恐慌，对吧？对，我想你大概可以这样辩论。我的意思是，很明显——呃，我不知道，也许苏西会不同意这一点，
but I think there is a human constant, isn't there, to look for scapegoats. And there are particular figures in society that end up being these folk devils. So older women, children, classically, and teenagers tend to be seen as folk devils, generation after generation so maybe disturbingly there is this i don't know suzy let me ask you a question um a slightly weird question
但我认为寻找替罪羊是人类的一种恒定心理，不是吗？社会上总有一些特定的人物最终成了这些民间恶魔。所以，年老的女性、儿童，经典地讲，还有青少年，一代又一代地往往被视为民间恶魔。所以，令人不安的是，可能确实存在这种——我不知道，苏西，让我问你一个问题，一个有点奇怪的问题：
if you were accused of being a witch what's your best way of getting out of it so how would you escape let me just first come to that point about teenagers and old women and i think perhaps the constant with children and teenagers and older women is that they're people that it's harder to control. I wonder if that's something to do with it. How do you best escape? Actually, sometimes you can escape by confessing to it. It depends where you are. So it depends on the jurisdiction you're operating in.
如果你被指控为女巫，你脱身的最绝佳方法是什么？你该如何逃脱？我先回答刚才关于青少年和老妇人的那个点。我想，儿童、青少年和老妇人的共同点或许在于，他们是更难被控制的人群。我不知道这是否与此有关。至于如何最好地逃脱？其实，有时你可以通过认罪来逃脱。这取决于你在哪里。也就是取决于你所处的司法管辖区。
In some places, people got away with it if they confessed and repented. That happened in Salem in New England, the trials in the 1692 outbreak. And it's those who refused to confess that died quite often. But often actually by naming other people, that might be a way out of it. That's kind of depressing, isn't it? But it's like Russia in the 1930s or something. Yeah, exactly. So if you can name people who were in large numbers who were there at your sabbat or whatever they've come up with as an idea,
在某些地方，如果人们认罪并忏悔，就能逃过一劫。1692年新英格兰的萨勒姆审判中就发生过这种情况。往往是那些拒绝认罪的人最终死去了。但通常情况下，实际上通过供出其他人，可能是脱身的一种方式。这听起来挺让人沮丧的，不是吗？但这就像1930年代的苏联一样。是的，完全如此。所以，如果你能供出大量曾与你在巫会（sabbat）上相聚或有其他牵连的人——
because quite often it's the interrogators' ideas that are being reproduced by those who are being interrogated, then maybe you've got a chance of being let off. And was the ducking stool, was that a real thing or is that a kind of children's history book invention? It's a real thing, but not for witches. It's a real thing that's used for scolds. So in exactly the same period that we have a rise in the number of people being executed as witches,
因为很多时候，这都是审讯人员的想法被受审者复述了出来——那么你或许还有机会被放过。那么，水刑（ducking stool）是真的存在，还是儿童历史书上虚构出来的？它是真实存在的，但不是针对女巫的。它是用来惩罚长舌妇（scolds）的。就在我们看到被处决为女巫的人数上升的同一时期，
we see basically there's a great sort of, how do we put it, intensification of patriarchy in this period of time. And so women who speak out, who are cantankerous or who are gossips or all these sort of things can be ductus scolds but it's basically it's just a confusion what we do have is what's called swimming which is in england um our swam um which uh which is um something that james the first writes about in his demonology, which is the following. You've got your witch, male or female.
基本上，我们看到——该怎么说呢——这一时期的父权制急剧强化。因此，那些大声说话、好争吵、爱说长道短或诸如此类行为的女性，可以被绑上水刑凳（scolds' bridle/ducking stool）。但基本上，这只是一种混淆。我们真正拥有的是所谓的“游水验巫”（swimming witches），在英格兰，我们称之为“游水”——
You strip them naked. You tie their thumbs to their toes. And you put them in a river to see if they're going to. Sorry, that's the dog. You put them in a river to see if they're going to sink. You're familiar. Yeah, my familiars are nearby. So if they are innocent, they will sink. And, you know, you hope they're going to be pulled out in time to not drown. And if they float, they are a witch. And the logic is that their baptism in waters no longer holds because they have turned to the devil and so the waters will reject them right okay so on that that thing of the of of rejecting your baptism and
詹姆士一世在他的《魔鬼学》（Demonology）中写到了这一点，具体过程如下。你把你的女巫，无论男女，扒光衣服，把她们的大拇指和小脚趾绑在一起，然后把她们扔进河里，看看她们会不会——抱歉，那是我的狗。你把她们扔进河里，看看她们会不会下沉。你很熟悉这个。对，我的熟悉精灵就在附近。所以，如果她们是无辜的，她们就会下沉。而且，你知道，你希望她们能及时被拉上来以免淹死。如果她们浮起来了，她们就是女巫。其逻辑是，她们在水中的洗礼不再有效，因为她们已经投向了魔鬼，因此水会拒绝她们。
you become a worshiper of the devil this idea that you are leaving the christian faith and that you were in a sense, taking up another faith. There was a very popular theory that this was an expression of a kind of ancient paganism that had survived Christianity. And I always remember my parents, when I was a child, had a book of kind of gazetteer to folklore. And they had a wonderful thing about the um the death of william ii in the new forest and this he'd been shot by an arrow and this supposedly was part of a a satanic ritual kind of wicker man style which a wicker man yes which i'd always which i'd always wanted to i'd always wanted to believe but um susie it's not true is is it? There was no such pagan cult lasting into the early modern period that witches were belonging to.
好吧，关于这种拒绝洗礼、成为魔鬼崇拜者的说法——这种你正在离开基督教信仰、在某种意义上转向另一种信仰的想法。曾有一种非常流行的理论认为，这是某种在基督教幸存下来的古代异教的表达。我总是记得我小时候，我父母有一本民俗指南手册，里面有一件极妙的事情，讲的是威廉二世（William II）在新森林（New Forest）的死。他被一支箭射中，这据称是“异教徒风格”的撒旦仪式的一部分——木头人（wicker man）式的仪式。一个木头人，是的。我一直——我一直都想去相信这个，但是，苏西，这不是真的，对吗？并没有什么延续到早期现代社会的异教徒邪教是女巫们所属的。
Well, I can say with great certainty there's no evidence to prove it. I can't say it's not true, but I can say there's perilous little to make a case for it. But Susie, that then raises the question, were any of the witches actually guilty? I, were any of the cases kind of banged to rights? They actually had been consorting. I mean, obviously they hadn't been consorting with the devil, but did they think they were witches?
嗯，我可以极其确定地说，没有证据证明这一点。我不能百分之百断言它绝不存在，但我可以说，支持这种说法的证据少得可怜。但苏西，这就引出了一个问题：那些女巫中真的有人有罪吗？我是说，其中有任何案件是证据确凿的吗？她们确实曾与魔鬼交往过？我的意思是，显然她们没有与魔鬼交往，但她们自己觉得自己是女巫吗？
I, had they been doing spells and did they have a, you know, a familiar and all this sort of business? Well, this is the amazing thing about the witchcraft trials is exactly this question. So many of us looking at this see this as one historian described it as a crime with a hole at the centre of it. There is nothing there and they're not doing anything. But clearly some of these people did think that they were acting as witches. At least that's what the confessions seem to suggest. Now, obviously, there are lots of confessions that are extracted under torture. But then there are also confessions that are freely given.
我是说，她们曾施过咒语，拥有熟悉精灵（familiar）以及所有这类的勾当吗？嗯，这正是巫术审判中最令人惊叹的问题。我们许多人看着这一切，认为这就像一位历史学家所描述的：“一个中心有一个空洞的犯罪”。那里什么也没有，她们什么也没做。但显然，其中一些人确实认为自己是在充当女巫。至少她们的供词似乎是这样暗示的。当然，有很多供词是在酷刑下逼供出来的。但同时也有一些供词是自愿给出的。
And some of those do seem to suggest that, and we can psychologise about what's going on there, but some of them do seem to suggest that people are saying they've met with the devil. And some of the interesting work, again, actually, from Linda Roper, has looked at the idea that what we're seeing is their fantasies, that quite a lot of the time these are people who are poor and dispossessed and who have very little. And they fantasize about meeting with the devil and him, you know, freeing them from hunger and from want and from poverty. And, you know, lots of feasting goes on with the devil because they're hungry or lots of sex because these people are untouched.
其中一些似乎确实暗示了这一点——我们可以对其中发生的事情进行心理分析——但其中一些确实表明，人们在说她们曾与魔鬼会面。而且，再次从琳达·罗珀那里得到了一些有趣的研究，她研究了这样一种观点：我们所看到的其实是她们的幻想。很多时候，这些人都是穷困潦倒、一无所有的人。她们幻想与魔鬼会面，幻想魔鬼让她们摆脱饥饿、匮乏和贫困。而且，你知道，由于她们常常挨饿，她们会与魔鬼进行盛宴狂欢；或者因为这些人在现实中无人触碰，所以会有很多性爱方面的幻想。
And so that actually what we're seeing there is an idea about what they lack and and this is a period um when the little ice age is kicking in um particularly in the 17th century it's a period of of cold and therefore of famine and therefore of hunger and do you think, is there a connection between the escalation of witchcraft trials and the fact that basically Europe is under massive stress at the time? Yes. Climatically.
因此，实际上我们在那里看到的是关于她们所匮乏之物的一种观念。而且这是一个——特别是在17世纪，小冰期开始席卷的时期——一个充满寒冷、饥荒和饥饿的时期。你认为巫术审判的升级与欧洲当时承受着巨大压力这一事实之间存在联系吗？从气候角度来说。
Absolutely. There's certainly the case that we've got, I think the thing about witchcraft is it is the sort of perfect storm, you know, it's an overused phrase, but it comes from all sorts of things happening at once, that you do have this extraordinary socioeconomic conditions where people are hungry, where in the 1590s, you have four years where it basically rains non-stop and there are, the harvests are destroyed and there's famine and, you know, bread prices shoot up. And whilst we can't do any sort of bald causality between, you know,
绝对有。毫无疑问，我们拥有——我认为关于巫术的关键在于，它是一场完美的风暴，这是一个被用滥了的词，但它源于各种事情同时发生。你确实拥有这种非同寻常的社会经济条件：人们在挨饿；在1590年代，连续下了四年不间断的雨，农作物被毁，发生了饥荒，面包价格飙升。虽然我们无法在“她们挨饿”与“人们被指控为巫术”之间建立某种直白的因果关系，但很显然，这就是巫术发生——无论是字面意义上的气候，还是更隐喻意义上的环境——巫术指控得以发生的背景。
they're hungry and then the people are accused of witchcraft, clearly this is the climate, both literally and sort of more metaphorically, in which witchcraft is happening, witchcraft accusations are happening. And Robin Briggs, who I mentioned earlier, did really good work on examining the details of neighborhood accusations so much of this is happening um between neighbors um between people who are who are hungry and envious between people who are being selfish and not operating as community norms say they should. One of the classic scenarios that Keith Thomas and Alec McFarlane came up with has been called the refusal guilt syndrome. So basically you have probably a older woman,
我前面提到的罗宾·布里格斯做过非常出色的研究，他详细考察了邻里之间的指控。这里面有很大一部分是发生在邻居之间——发生在饥饿且嫉妒的人之间，发生在那些自私自利、没有按照社区规范行事的人之间。基斯·托马斯（Keith Thomas）和亚历克·麦克法兰（Alec Macfarlane）提出的经典场景之一被称为“拒绝-内疚综合征”（refusal guilt syndrome）。基本上，你可能会有一个年老的女性，
somebody who is in need, going to the door of a richer, not particularly rich, but richer householder and asking for alms. And maybe in England, because they've started giving alms through the parish, they think they've already done enough. So they turn this person away. She mutters under her breath as she leaves. And then, you know, a cow gets sick or a child dies and they accuse her of witchcraft. So there's a lot of projection onto these poorer people that they must be angry. There's a sense that they must be acting against the richer people because it's about guilt. So I think the fact that people are hungry and angry makes a big difference. And I suppose also it kind of provides a reassurance that there is an explanation for these awful things happening rather than just, you know, shit happens.
一个需要帮助的人，走到一个比较富有（其实也算不上特别富有，但比她富裕）的户主家门口去讨施舍。也许在英格兰，因为他们已经开始通过教区发放救济，他们觉得自己已经做得够多了。于是他们把这个人赶走。她在离开时低声咕哝着诅咒。然后，你知道，一头牛生病了，或者一个孩子夭折了，他们就指控她使用了巫术。因此，人们将许多负面情绪投射到这些穷人身上，认为他们一定心怀怨恨。人们会有一种感觉：他们肯定在对富人采取报复行动，因为这关乎内疚感。所以我想，人们又饿又愤怒这一事实，造成了巨大的差异。我想这也提供了一种心理安慰，让人们觉得这些可怕事情的发生是有原因的，而不仅仅是“操蛋的事情总会发生”。
Anyway, on that note, shit happens, which could really be the motto. That should be our title. We missed that out. Let's take a break. And when we come back, we will return to the dark arts with Susie. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works.
总之，基于“操蛋的事情总会发生”这一点——这真的可以成为我们的座右铭。那本该是我们的标题。我们漏掉了。我们休息一下吧。回来后，我们将和苏西一起重返黑魔法的世界。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、八卦爆料。在我们的问答环节中，我们将拉开娱乐行业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。
We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hi, welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are talking witches and witchcraft and we've got all your questions. We're about to go through them, very selfishly i've got one question that i i would like to put susie before we get on to yours um and that is really to go back to the gender of witches because one thing you talked about the malius maleficarum um and and their witches are described as as female it's a it's a female noun um but in the Vulgate, the Latin version of the Bible that people would read in the Middle Ages, the famous line that's translated in the
我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告音频、加更节目并抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。嗨，欢迎回到《历史的余烬》。我们正在谈论女巫与巫术，我们收到了你们所有的提问。我们马上就要解答这些问题了。非常自私地，我在进入你们的问题之前，想先问苏西一个问题——那就是真正回到女巫的性别问题上。因为你谈到了《女巫之锤》，那里的女巫被描述为女性，这是一个阴性名词。但在《武加大译本》（Vulgate，中世纪人们阅读的拉丁语圣经版本）中，那句在《詹姆士王钦定本圣经》（King James Bible）《出埃及记》中被翻译为“不可容留行邪术的女人活著”的名词，其实是“malefico”，是一个阳性词。再次请问，为什么在中世纪到早期现代的过程中，人们对女巫的看法似乎发生了一种演变，从阳性变成了阴性？这背后的原因是什么？
King James Bible, thou shalt not suffer a witch to live in Exodus, that word, it's malefico, so it's a masculine. And again, just why is it that over the course of the Middle Ages into the early modern period, there seems to be this evolution of thinking of witches as masculine and then becoming female? What's going on there? So the Malleus Maleficarum was a particularly misogynistic text. So the writer conceived of witches as female and that's the sort of dominant theme and it would have been,
所以，《女巫之锤》是一部特别厌女的文本。因此，作者将女巫构想为女性，这是其主导主题，即使在当时，它也表现出惊人的厌女症。但我们看到的一种信念是，男性和女性都可以是女巫。在某些地方，被指控为巫术的男性实际上比女性更多。例如在冰岛，17世纪被指控巫术的人中有92%是男性；在俄罗斯，这一比例大约是68%；在爱沙尼亚，这一比例非常高；在诺曼底，男性的数量超过女性三比一。但在其他地方，情况发生了转变，大约五分之四的女巫是女性。因为虽然人们认为男女都有可能被魔鬼诱惑，但女性被认为更为软弱，更容易轻信，更容易陷入罪恶——特别是性罪恶——在这一历史时期，人们普遍是这样认为的，因此她们也更倾向于被引诱背离
even for its time, surprisingly misogynistic. But what we see is a belief that both men and women can be witches and in some places there are more men accused of witchcraft than women in Iceland for example 92 percent of those accused of witchcraft in the 17th century are male in Russia it's something 68 percent Estonia it's very high Normandy the males outnumber females three to one but elsewhere it's the it shifts and it's more like four out of five witches are female because whilst both men and women are thought capable of being seduced by the devil women are weaker it's thought more credulous more likely to fall into sin particularly sexual sin it's thought, more credulous, more likely to fall into sin, particularly sexual sin, it's thought, in this period of time, and therefore more likely to be persuaded away from
真理。那么那些被指控的男性，他们是某种边缘男性吗？也就是说，他们是某种独行者、怪胎或处于社会边缘的人吗？还是说他们可能是社区中心的人物？在某些地方，他们确实更边缘化。因此，俄罗斯的案件似乎主要针对牧师或流民、四处游荡的流浪汉。所以我们确实看到了一些这种边缘性。但我们也看到了许多主流男性被指控的实例。那么，约翰·迪伊博士（Dr. Dee）——伊丽莎白一世时期忙着观察天使、做各种事情的那个人——他是怎么逃脱的？
the truth. And are the men that are accused, are they sort of marginal men? So are they kind of loners and oddballs or people on the fringe? Or could they be people at the centre of the community? In some places, they are more marginal. So the Russian cases appear to be looking at people who are shepherds or vagrants, people who are moving around, wanderers. So we do have some of that marginality. But we also do see instances of very mainstream men accused as well. So how does Dr. D, Elizabeth I, who's busy looking at angels or doing all kinds of stuff, how does he get away with it?
我想他算是一个巫师（wizard），而不是女巫（witch）。因为到了这个时候，女巫的定义是你正在实践“maleficarum”（邪术），你通过魔法行恶，而他并没有行恶。他从事的是——白魔法是可以的吗？是的，我的意思是，这当然是有问题的，不是吗？它依然是有问题的，而且这两者之间的界限非常容易跨越。我想，他拥有伊丽莎白一世的庇护对他的帮助很大。我的意思是，他行事的方式就像伊丽莎白一世一样，对炼金术非常感兴趣，试图寻找哲人石。正如格伦·帕里（Glenn Parry）关于迪伊的研究所示，伊丽莎白一世在她的宫殿里设有炼金实验室。所以我认为他追求的是一种——可以说是——获得国家批准的魔法。而且因为它是公开的，我想他没有隐瞒任何事情，不像是在某个橱柜后面偷偷摸摸地做。我的意思是，这难道不是那种如果你试图掩盖它或者做别的什么，看起来反而比你大大方方承认“我是一名炼金术士，我正在施展法术”更可疑的事情吗？
I suppose he's a sort of wizard as opposed to a witch. So the definition of witch by this point is that you're practising maleficarum, that you're doing evil through magic and he's not doing evil um he's so white white magic is okay yes i mean there's a certainly problematic isn't it it's still problematic and the line between the two is is very easy to cross um i suppose the fact that he's got the patronage of elizabeth the first helps um i mean and he's operating to just much like elizabeth the
我确信是这样的。我认为这关乎他在社会中的权力层级。很大程度上，这就归结为：往往是那些没有权力的人，才会被指控试图利用这种非法获得的权力去做些什么。好的，这就引出了温策尔·罗斯纳（Wenzel Rosner）的一个好问题。他说——我假设这是一个他，我其实不知道温策尔是谁，我对这个人一无所知。不管怎样，温策尔说，普通女性
first did i'm very interested in alchemy he's very interested in uh trying to find the philosopher's stone um as glenn parry's written about d and shown that elizabeth the first had alchemical laboratories in her palaces so i think that he's pursuing a sort of magic as it were that is state approved and because it's open i suppose he's not hiding anything is it's not like he's doing it you know in the back of a cupboard i mean he's sort of isn't it one of those things that if you try to cover it up or whatever it looks more dodgy than if you're say well i'm an alchemist i'm i'm casting spells i'm sure that's right. And I think it's about his level of power in society. So much of this comes down to it's those who don't have power
会担心被指控为巫术吗？换句话说，你是生活在对猎巫人的恐惧之中，还是可以过着你的日常生活，而从未假设过这种事会降临到自己头上？我想这取决于谁、在什么时候以及在什么地方。因为在某些时期，围绕巫术的文化、
who are accused of trying to do something with this illegally gotten power. Okay, so that brings up a good question actually from Wenzel Rosner. And he, I assume it's he, I don't really know what Wenzel is I don't know anything about this person anyway, Wenzel says would the average woman
对巫术的担忧会被放大，所以我认为即使是一个普通的女性也可能会被指控。但我确实认为，巫术的名声需要时间来积累，有时它们源于某种家族传统——你的家庭成员、祖母、母亲被认为是女巫。而且这需要多次指控，它不是第一次发生就会这样的。因为如果你认为某人是女巫，在指控她之前你需要确凿的证据，对吧？她们手里可是掌握着邪恶的魔法。所以我们往往会在审判中发现这样的参考记录：这发生在20年前，这发生在10年前。这意味着人们经常谈论巫术。他们谈论它的频率，远比我们手头能拿出来的审判案例所显示的要多得多，
have been worried about being accused of witchcraft, in other words are you living in fear of witch hunters or could you just go about your daily life you know, without assuming it would never happen to you I suppose it depends who and when where because there would have been certain periods where the culture around witchcraft
因为这意味着会有很多人根本没有进入审判程序。但我认为，你必须针对某人积累相当大量的证据才能指控她，这意味着你其实会知道别人是否会认为你是个女巫。安德烈（Andre）提出了一个后续问题：有没有人被指控为女巫——并且据推测被定罪了——然后却被无罪释放的例子？基本上，一旦你被裁定犯有巫术罪，那就是板上钉钉了吗？还是说你还有机会——确实有人没有被定罪，也有人没有被处决。所以有一个
the concerns around witchcraft would have been heightened and so i think even an ordinary woman could be accused but i do think that witchcraft reputations took time to build up and sometimes they came from a sort of family tradition your you know family members grandmother mother thought to be witches and it took many accusations it didn't it wasn't on the first time so because if you think someone's a witch you don, you need to be sure before you accuse them, right? They've got evil magic at their disposal. So we tend to find that in the trials, we get references to this happened 20 years ago, this happened 10 years ago. So that means people are talking about witchcraft a lot. They're talking about it much more than we have trial cases uh to show for it
例子，例如英格兰著名的爆发事件之一是1612年的彭德尔（Pendel）审判。同一年在兰开夏郡（Lancashire），同样在兰开夏郡，发生了被称为萨姆斯伯里女巫（Salmsbury witches）的案件，有三名女性被一个14岁的女孩指控。结果发现这个女孩是被教唆的，于是这些女性被无罪释放并宣告无罪。所以确实有无罪释放的情况，也确实不是每个人都被处决。据我们估计，这一时期大约有90,000人被当作女巫起诉，其中大约有一半人被处决。
because then there's going to be lots of people who don't make it to trial but i think you have to have quite a substantial body of evidence against someone to accuse them so that means that you're going to know whether people are going to think you're a witch or not there's there's a follow-up on that from a question from andre um are there examples of of people who are accused of being a witch and presumably convicted only then to get off so basically once you've been once you've been convicted of witchcraft was was that it um or did you have a chance of there are people who aren't convicted and there are people who aren't executed so there's an
因为接下来会有很多人无法进入审判程序，但我认为你必须掌握相当大量的证据才能指控某人，这意味着你将清楚地知道别人是否会认为你是女巫。安德烈有一个后续问题：呃，有没有人被指控为女巫并据推测被定罪，然后却被无罪释放的例子？基本上，一旦你被判定犯有巫术罪，那就是定局了吗？还是说你还有机会……有些人并未被定罪，也有人没有被处决，所以有一个
instance for example one of the famous outbreaks in England is the Pendle, which is 1612. And in the same year in Lancashire, also in Lancashire, what are known as the Salmsbury witches, there are three women accused by a 14-year-old girl. And it's discovered that the girl has been coached and the women are set free and acquitted. So there are acquittals and it's certainly true that not everyone is executed. So we think there are about 90,000 people who are prosecuted as witches in this period and about half of those are executed as witches.
例如，英国著名的巫术爆发事件之一是1612年的潘德尔审判。同年在兰开夏郡，同样在兰开夏郡，发生了被称为萨姆斯伯里女巫的案件，有三名女性被一个14岁的女孩指控。后来发现这个女孩受到了教唆，这些女性被无罪释放。因此确实存在无罪释放的情况，而且并非所有人都会被处决。据我们估计，这一时期大约有9万人被作为女巫起诉，其中大约有一半人被当作女巫处决。
So it is possible to get away with it, as it were, get away with innocence. You mentioned the Pendle witch trials, and Cain Carlyle asked a question about that. So Cain says, can you talk about the witch trials and their links with the English Reformation? On a side note, Pendle Hill is a stunning place to go for a lockdown walk, Cain also says.
所以逃脱惩罚是有可能的，可以说是逃脱了清白。你提到了彭德尔女巫审判，凯恩·卡莱尔就此提问。凯恩问道：你能聊聊女巫审判以及它们与英国宗教改革的联系吗？顺便说一句，凯恩还说，彭德尔山是个适合在封城期间散步的好地方。
Sounds suspicious to me, very suspicious. So the links with the English Re reformation what's all this about um i i mean i think there's a lot more going on than links to the english reformation there i suppose as usual we've got um the we've got a background of uh religious change we've this is so when religious change. This is... So, Susie, when is this? This is 1612. So, crucially, I suppose, what's happened is that James VI of Scotland
听起来很可疑，非常可疑。所以说与英国宗教改革的联系，这到底是怎么回事呢，嗯……我的意思是，我觉得除了与英国宗教改革的联系之外，还有很多其他因素。我想就像往常一样，我们有宗教变革的背景，这就是当宗教变革发生时。这是……所以，苏西，这是什么时候？这是1612年。因此，至关重要的是，我想，发生的事情是苏格兰国王詹姆斯六世
has become James I of England. And James VI of Scotland had written a book called Demonology in 1597 in which he had given people instructions on how to find witches. And so we're in a period in which this Protestant has come to the throne of England and those who are thought to be practising witchcraft are being supported at this you know seriously elite level at the level of the monarch um there is a sense that uh people can rightfully pursue witches um but there's and so that's part of the background for Macbeth isn't it it is it is
成为了英格兰国王詹姆斯一世。苏格兰国王詹姆斯六世在1597年写过一本名为《恶魔学》的书，在书中他向人们提供了如何寻找女巫的指示。因此，我们正处于这样一个时期：这位新教徒登上了英格兰的王位，那些被认为在练习巫术的人正受到这种极其精英级别的支持，达到了君主的级别，人们有一种感觉，即人们可以理所当然地追捕女巫，但这正是《麦克白》背景的一部分，对吧？是的，确实如此，
absolutely which we opened with that's right yes exactly written in the 1590s, precisely at the sort of time that there are trials in the 1590s in North Berwick, which James VI at the time oversees. So in 1612, we've got witches who are being accused in that climate. But one of them, who's known as Old Demdike, has been accused of being a witch for 50 years. So it's not just about those circumstances. People have been thinking of her as a witch for a long time. And there are lots of associations with some of the ideas about witchcraft that we might pursue. We might think of her as even voodoo. For example, Old Demdike makes these clay figures that she sticks pins into that will injure the people that she's cursing. So it's a really
绝对是的，我们开篇就提到了，没错，对的，确切地说，它写于1590年代，正值1590年代北贝里克发生审判的那段时间，詹姆斯六世当时亲自监督了审判。所以在1612年，我们在这种氛围下迎来了被指控的女巫。但其中一个被称为老戴姆戴克的人，已经被指控为女巫50年了。所以这不仅仅是关于那些情况。人们很早就认为她是女巫了。这里有很多与我们可能会探讨的一些巫术观念的联系。我们甚至可以认为她就像巫毒教一样。例如，老戴姆戴克制作了这些黏土人偶，并在上面插上大头针，从而伤害她正在诅咒的人。所以这对于英格兰来说是一个真正
interesting case for England because it's quite large scale for England. It's sort of 12 people accused of witchcraft and 10 of them are executed. And the one I've mentioned, Old Demdike, Elizabeth Southerns dies in jail it's nothing by comparison to the scale of things in Germany but it's quite big for England right we've got another question from Stephen Clark um going forward now when if ever and why did the British Isles see a significant decline in popular belief in magic and the supernatural that's a huge question um I mean let's narrow that down when what's the process by which the belief in witchcraft in not just in britain across europe starts to fade so i suppose we could say that
有趣的案件，因为对英格兰而言规模相当大。大约有12人被控巫术，其中10人被处决。而我提到的那个人，老戴姆戴克，伊丽莎白·索瑟恩斯在狱中死去，与德国的规模相比这算不了什么，但对英格兰来说已经相当大了。好，我们有来自斯蒂芬·克拉克的另一个问题，接下来要探讨的是：英国群岛什么时候、如果有的话，为什么会出现对魔法和超自然现象的普遍信仰的显著衰落？这是一个巨大的问题，嗯，我的意思是，让我们缩小范围，人们对巫术的信仰开始消退的过程是什么，不仅仅是在英国，而是在整个欧洲？所以我想我们可以说，
in the later 17th century um and early 18th century we see a changing idea about who can be convicted of witchcraft it's not quite the same thing as people stopping believing in witchcraft and i'm not sure that people necessarily did i suppose we see some evidence of change in terms of what you know scientific revolutions it's called the you know the enlightenment perhaps we see changes there but chiefly what we see evidence of is changes in beliefs about evidence what are the grounds on which someone can be convicted of witchcraft and at the same time as we have in america in the salem witch trials we have people who are being convicted on the strength of what are known as spectral evidence so that those who are
在17世纪后期和18世纪初期，我们看到关于谁可以被判犯有巫术罪的观念发生了变化。这与人们停止相信巫术并不完全是一回事，而且我也不确定人们是否真的不再相信了。我想我们从科学革命的角度看到了一些变化的证据，也就是所谓的启蒙运动，也许我们在那里看到了变化，但主要是我们看到的证据是关于证据信念的变化。一个人被判犯有巫术罪的依据是什么？与此同时，就像我们在美国的塞勒姆审判中所看到的那样，有些人仅仅凭所谓的幽灵证据就被定罪，也就是说那些
accusing them are possessed by the specter of this witch and also on their own confessions we have the evidence from the home assizes the court circuit of trials saying actually um they're they're just there's no evidence against them apart from their own confession, and this isn't good enough. And that's a radical change, whereas 60 years earlier, it had been the strength of the confession that had convicted witches. So it's more about that than about a change in beliefs. And some people still do believe in witchcraft. And we see some people who are pursuing witches, when the members of the elites won't do it at law they're going to pursue them with a mob in the 18th century but the last person to be executed
指控他们的人被这个女巫的幽灵所附体，还有他们自己的供词。我们从王室巡回法院的审判记录中得到的证据表明，实际上，除了他们自己的供词之外，没有任何证据可以证明他们有罪，而这还远远不够。这是一个根本性的变化，而在60年前，正是靠着供词的力度才给女巫定罪的。所以这更多的是关于证据观念的变化，而不是信仰本身的变化。有些人仍然相信巫术。我们看到有些人仍在追捕女巫，当精英阶层不肯依法行事时，他们在18世纪会组织暴民去追捕她们，但在英国，最后一个被处决的
for witchcraft is in england in 1685 and in scotland in 1722 because in the 20th century i mean that that idea that there was a kind of pagan, often female-centred religion in the background of the Christian Middle Ages. Yes, yes, yes, which I think is pronounced Witcher originally. OK. Kind of really giving you a hint of what's going on there. And that becomes kind of, that becomes the basis for 20th century paganism. And I suppose that more recently, most obviously in children's books, so the worst witch first, and then
因巫术罪而被处决的人是在1685年（英格兰）和1722年（苏格兰）。因为在20世纪，我的意思是，那种认为基督教中世纪背景下存在一种异教的、通常以女性为中心的宗教的想法。是的，是的，是的，最初的发音好像是Witcher。好的。这真的给了你一点暗示，到底是怎么回事。这成为了20世纪新异教主义的基础。而且我想最近，最明显的例子是在童书里，先是《女巫闹翻天》，然后是
most famously Harry Potter, which is basically, I mean, Hermione Granger is a witch, isn't she? I mean, she's kind of the hero. Yeah. Although Bellatrix Lestrange is a very kind of stereotypical witch, and she's a baddie. So, you know, she's kind of dark, mad hair, and Helena Bonham Carter, and you know she's kind of dark mad hair and helena
最著名的《哈利·波特》，基本上，我的意思是，赫敏·格兰杰就是一个女巫，不是吗？我的意思是，她有点像主角。是的。尽管贝拉特里克斯·莱斯特兰奇是一个非常典型的女巫形象，而且她是个大反派。所以，你知道，她有点像黑色的、疯狂的头发，还有海伦娜·伯翰·卡特，你知道她有点黑色的、疯狂的头发，还有海伦娜
bonham carter and you can imagine her on a broomstick and stuff so there's still some of the old helena bonham carter's always playing with yeah i mean it's basically anyway suzy go on sorry i'm interrupting no you're not i mean the interesting thing there is that we do have both the idea of a witch being uh evil uh black as it were, and the idea of white magic that we mentioned earlier. That's what comes out in the 20th century and it's what comes out in children's stories. So that very much you can have Hermione Granger who's a witch but using magic for good. And I think that many of the people who identify with being a witch today or practicing Wicca feel that they have a lineage to the witches who were accused in the 16th century, whether that's true or not.
伯翰·卡特，你可以想象她骑着扫帚之类的样子，所以仍然有一些老的海伦娜·伯翰·卡特总是在扮演……是的，我的意思是这基本上……不管怎样，苏西，你继续，抱歉我打断了。不，你没有。我的意思是，有趣的是，我们既有女巫是邪恶的、用我们的话说是黑魔法的想法，也有我们之前提到的白魔法的想法。这就是20世纪所呈现出来的，也是儿童故事中所呈现出来的。所以你可以有很多像赫敏·格兰杰这样的人，她是个女巫，但用魔法做好事。而且我认为今天许多认同自己是女巫或实践威卡教的人觉得他们与16世纪被指控的女巫有着某种血缘关系，不管这是真是假。
And they, particularly one of the things that comes out, I'm often asked whether it's to do with being healers, whether they were people who were what was called cunning men and women in the 16th century and who were conjuring up potions using herbs to heal people and certainly many of them may have been that the evidence is quite hard to follow on that through the trials but there is a sense today and in the 20th century that surely magic could be used for good. And throwing it even further forward to the present day, to the 21st century, I mean, the question that we got a lot when we advertised this subject, we get it from Neil Page, for example, he says, what's the modern version of the witch trials? And you see this
而且他们，特别是一个引人注目的现象是，我经常被问到这是否与治愈者有关，他们是否是16世纪被称为精明男女的人，他们用草药调制药水来治愈人们。当然，他们中的许多人可能确实如此，在审判中很难追踪到明确的证据，但在今天和20世纪，人们有一种感觉，即魔法肯定可以用来做好事。把时间进一步推到今天，推到21世纪，我的意思是，当我们宣传这个主题时，我们得到了很多问题，例如尼尔·帕奇问的，他说：现代版的女巫审判是什么样的？你会看到这个
all the time, particularly on social media, people talking about witch hunts and how particular women, we mentioned J.K. Rowling without getting into the kind of ins and outs of that debate but particular women become stigmatized and scapegoated and is there any you know is obviously we use the terminology of the witch and the witch hunt but do you think there is any kind of continuity any parallel or is it purely a sort of metaphor i think there are parallels with punishments in the 16th century, though not so much that that was dealt out to witches. I think what we see today reflects the sort of religious punishments that happened, for example, the Protestant church in Scotland or in France
一直都在发生，特别是在社交媒体上，人们谈论女巫狩猎，以及特定的女性——我们提到J.K.罗琳，而不深入探讨那场辩论的细节——特定的女性是如何被污名化和作为替罪羊的。这其中有什么（你知道的，显然我们使用了女巫和女巫狩猎的术语），但你认为这其中有任何连续性、任何平行性，或者它纯粹是一种隐喻吗？我认为这与16世纪的惩罚有相似之处，尽管这些惩罚并非专门针对女巫。我认为我们今天看到的情况反映了那种宗教惩罚，例如苏格兰或法国的新教教会
dealt out shaming punishments. And what we see on social media is this large-scale shaming that happens, of course, John Ronson wrote about it. And so I suppose that's what we would say when we're talking about a witch hunt today, that somebody's life is made so uncomfortable that they are considered a persona non grata. They don't end up dead, but they might end up socially dead. Dominic, do we have any other questions?
施加的羞辱性惩罚。我们在社交媒体上看到的是这种大规模的羞辱，当然，约翰·朗森曾对此进行过写作。所以我想这就是我们在今天谈论女巫狩猎时所要表达的意思，即某人的生活变得如此令人痛苦，以至于他们被认为是不受欢迎的人（persona non grata）。他们没有死，但他们在社会上可能已经死了。多米尼克，我们还有其他问题吗？
Rather good question from Felma Dinkley, I see. They don't end up dead, but they might end up socially dead. Dominic, do we have any other questions? A rather good question from Velma Dinkley, I see. Thanks, Dad. Yeah, Velma Dinkley, I can read. Velma Dinkley says, How were witches regarded... Oh, come on, Thomas. Oh, jeez, I've fallen for that one. OK.
我看到费尔马·丁克利提出了一个相当不错的问题。他们没有死，但他们在社会上可能已经死了。多米尼克，我们还有其他问题吗？我看到维尔玛·丁克利提出了一个相当不错的问题。谢谢，爸爸。是的，维尔玛·丁克利，我认得字。维尔玛·丁克利问：女巫在……哦，得了吧，托马斯。哦，天哪，我中计了。好吧。
How were witches regarded in Roman, pagan, pre-Christian times? Please answer, Susie, in such a way that Tom cannot add anything of worth to your answer. There's no way I'm doing that in Tom's presence. Could I just very quickly answer that one? Please do. Are you Velma Dinkley? I'm not at liberty to reveal whether i am velma dinkley
在罗马、异教、基督教前时期，人们是如何看待女巫的？苏西，请回答这个问题，回答的方式要让汤姆无法对你的回答做出任何有价值的补充。在汤姆在场的情况下，我绝不可能做到这一点。我能非常简短地回答这个问题吗？请便。你是维尔玛·丁克利吗？我无权透露我是不是维尔玛·丁克利
but it's an excellent question um well thank you velma for asking that question so witches um were absolute theme of roman poets they were obsessed by them very hard thing for roman poet who doesn't portray a figure of a sinister old woman who kind of grubs around in graveyards digging up bones and making potions with ashes and I'm sure I mean I don't know when but I'm sure that that this must then feed into what the the friars and the dominicans and the protestant divines are reading and kind of creating from it but I think also the other thing that um must feed into the witch scare in the in the 16th century is the sense the Romans and people across the Mediterranean have that there are kind of malign figures. So the Romans have striges who are kind of female figures who fly through the air and who feed on the hapless. There's an amazing story told of Apollonius of Tyana.
但这真的是一个极好的问题。嗯，谢谢维尔玛提出这个问题。所以女巫是罗马诗人们绝对的主题，他们对女巫着迷已久。对于一个罗马诗人来说，如果不刻画一个险恶的老太婆形象——她在墓地里乱翻、挖掘骨头并用骨灰制作药水——是很难办到的。而且我确信，我的意思是，我不知道是什么时候，但我确信这必定会影响到修士、多米尼克修道士和新教神学家们所阅读的内容，并从中创造出一些东西。但我认为，另一个必然会助长16世纪女巫恐慌的因素是罗马人和地中海各地的人们所感受到的一种观念，即存在着某种恶毒的形象。所以罗马人有斯特里杰斯（striges），它们是一种在空中飞翔并以倒霉的人为食的女性形象。关于蒂安娜的阿波罗尼奥斯，有一个惊人的故事。
Who's a kind of Jesus figure. He's often parallel to Jesus. Who turns up at Ephesus I think. And Ephesus is plagued by all kinds of hideous witchcraft. And they ask Apollonius what's going on. And he points to a poor beggar who sat at the gate. With his asking for alms. And Apollonius says that's the guy. Stone him. is you know what's going on and he points to a poor beggar who's sat at the gate with his his asking for arms and apollonia says that's the guy stone him and it's a bit like monty python
他是一个类似耶稣的人物。他经常与耶稣作比较。我想他出现在以弗所。而以弗所正饱受各种可怕巫术的困扰。他们问阿波罗尼奥斯发生了什么事。他指向一个坐在大门口的穷乞丐，乞求施舍。阿波罗尼奥斯说那就是那个家伙，用石头砸死他。你知道是怎么回事，他指向一个坐在大门口的穷乞丐，乞求施舍，阿波罗尼奥斯说那就是那个家伙，用石头砸死他，这有点像巨蟒剧团（Monty Python），
but beggar says i'm not i've nothing to do with it and everyone says no he's not he's just a harmless beggar and apollonia says stone him so they all stone him and he gets buried beneath a great pile of stones and then he turns into an evil dog and howls and dies. So I think that, you know, there's all kinds of elements there. The idea of flying through the air, the idea that human beings can become animals, the idea of familiars. I guess it's all kind of the brew of stuff that scholars in the 16th century can read and then can kind of form this cocktail of what a witch should properly be. I mean, do you think that's what's happening? I think that's right. I mean, I think what we've got going on by the time we get to the 16th century is you've got
但乞丐说我不是，我跟这事没关系，每个人都说不，他不是，他只是一个无害的乞丐，而阿波罗尼奥斯说用石头砸死他，于是他们都用石头砸他，他被埋在了一大堆石头下面，然后他变成了一只邪恶的狗，嚎叫着死去了。所以我认为，这里面包含了各种各样的元素。在空中飞行的概念，人类可以变成动物的概念，熟悉精灵的概念。我想这都是16世纪学者们所能阅读的各种材料的大杂烩，然后他们可以借此调制出关于女巫究竟应该是什么样子的鸡尾酒。我的意思是，你认为这就是正在发生的事情吗？我认为是这样的。我的意思是，我认为当我们进入16世纪时，我们看到的是
two discourses about witchcraft. At one level, you've got what the elites are saying, which is absolutely going to be informed by their new humanistic renaissance study of classical texts and is going to have those elements and so they're thinking about them flying through the air maybe backwards on a goat or maybe on a broomstick and at the same time you've got what is believed at a village level um and this all those neighborhood accusations and the sort of i was going to say the magic the the terrible thing that happens is that those two connect right that's that those those two beliefs which are really probably quite different connect up and are thought to be the same thing um i was i wrote a forward for a book
关于巫术的两种论述。在一个层面上，你有精英们的言论，这绝对会受到他们对古典文本进行的新人文学派文艺复兴研究的影响，并且会包含那些元素，所以他们可能会认为她们骑着山羊倒飞在空中，或者骑着扫帚飞翔；而在同一时间，你拥有在村庄层面上人们所相信的东西，所有这些邻里之间的指控，以及那种——我本想说魔法——可怕的事情是，这两种观点结合在了一起，对吧？那两个实际上可能完全不同的信念结合在了一起，并被认为是同一回事。我曾为一本书写过序言
which is called a history of magic witchcraft and Occult. And that looks at witchcraft beliefs across the world throughout time. And there are many strands that come out as being similar in different, really radically different societies. But it is interesting to consider the ways in which there is a lineage that these ideas are being passed on. And do you think it will always be with us then? do you think witches and witchcraft will always be with us so in this sort of visions of the 27th century that you have there are no witches but actually is that unrealistic and we'll always be you know looking dominic something beyond are you asking susie to look into the future i am that's exactly what i'm tempting her into the practice of witchcraft. Yeah, I have indeed. I shall look into my crystal ball.
这本书叫《魔法、巫术与神秘学史》。它审视了世界各地、各个历史时期的巫术信仰。在不同的、实际上截然不同的社会中，有许多相似的线索脱颖而出。但考虑到这些理念得以传承的血脉，确实很有趣。那么你认为它会永远伴随着我们吗？你认为女巫和巫术会永远伴随着我们吗？所以，在你对27世纪的这种展望中，没有女巫，但实际上这是否不切实际，我们是否总是会寻找——多米尼克，超越这一切的东西——你是让苏西去展望未来吗？我是，这正是我引诱她去做的巫术实践。是的，我确实这么做了。我将通过我的水晶球来寻找答案。
I think that there will always be things that humans can't explain and that the desire to explain them and to control them will mean that people may well um point to uh other forces to deal with what is uncertain and what is inexplicable and i suppose so that can in other words that is a sort of where the witch comes in you know yeah and the scapegoating as well will surely always, I mean, that's, you know, it's part of being human, isn't it? Unfortunately. Yes. I mean, it was what we were talking about earlier with the climate change. You've got, somebody's got to be to blame. And now perhaps we'd like to think that we wouldn't blame that because we would recognise the scientific change.
我认为总会有一些人类无法解释的事情，而解释和控制这些事情的欲望将意味着人们很可能会把矛头指向其他力量，来处理那些不确定和无法解释的事情。所以换句话说，这就是女巫登场的地方，对吧？还有寻找替罪羊的做法也肯定会一直存在，我的意思是，这是身为人类的一部分，不是吗？不幸的是。是的。我的意思是，这正是我们之前谈论气候变化时所讨论的。总得有人来承担责任。现在也许我们愿意认为我们不会那样去指责别人，因为我们会认识到科学的变革。
But I think we still do see scapegoating in different ways. So unless humans change, I'm not sure the witches are going to be eradicated, really. Well, do you know, I think the hurly-burly's done. Susie, can't thank you enough for coming on the show and all your learning, all your wisdom and scholarship. And thank you, everyone who's listening. A reminder that we're producing two pods a week
但我认为我们仍然以不同的方式看到寻找替罪羊的现象。所以除非人类改变，否则我不太确定女巫会被真正彻底根除。好吧，你知道吗，我觉得喧嚣已经结束了。苏西，非常感谢你来到节目中，感谢你的所有学识、智慧和造诣。也谢谢每一位收听节目的听众。提醒一下，我们目前每周制作两期播客
at the moment. Mondays and Thursdays are the days to keep an eye out for us. See you soon, I hope. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
每周一和周四是我们的更新日，记得关注我们。希望不久后能再见。感谢收听《历史的剩余部分》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取独家节目、提前收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。